[Music]
today we're filming a music video to
promote ABC Family's pop-up Santa
campaign the pop-up Santa campaign is
where ABC family finds fun unexpected
ways to surprise viewers during the
[Music]
holiday I always wanted to be a part of
an Acappella group and I love Christmas
songs so this is a treat for
me could be your town you never know
where yes and make sure on these next
two you over pronounce I love working
with the scatter tones they're so
talented they have amazing energy and
I'm genuinely having a really great day
with
them
when I first heard about the pop-up
Santa campaign I really wanted to be a
part of it the holiday season is upon us
and spreading happiness to people makes
me feel good y we were
[Music]
perfect